l'europe a donc 30 ans bon anniversaire
les 320 millions d'européens fait
aujourd'hui cet anniversaire c'était le
25 mars 1957 la signature du traité de
rome instituant la communauté économique
européenne la france est l'un des pays
de la communauté qui célèbre avec rue
avec avec le plus de faste cet
anniversaire et ce matin une cérémonie
réunissait à l'arc de triomphe le
président de la république et le premier
ministre bruno le dress
fond bleu frappé de douze étoiles jaunes
le drapeau européen était de rigueur ce
matin avec une première pour fêter le
trentième anniversaire de la signature
du traité de rome les champs elysées
pavoisée aux couleurs de l'europe tout
le monde a aimé mon père a fait la
guerre 14 18 mois salle de 39-45 et les
spectacles de nouveau conflit n'éclate
pas en europe et c'est pour ça que je
suis évidemment partisan d'une europe
vous sentez plus france est plus
européen là on sent plus français qu'un
repère et 24 sont indéniables savait
difficile de faire l'europe si les
français sont plus français les
allemands musellement quelque chose
c'est au-dessus des nations c'est c'est
comme les états unis avec des états mais
là ce sera à l'échelle européenne avec
avec des pays européens
le président de la république a remonté
les champs elysées en voiture jusqu'à
l'arc de triomphe où l'attendait le
premier ministre et les ambassadeurs des
onze autres états membres de l'europe
chacun a déposé une gerbe sur la tombe
du soldat inconnu il s'agit de montrer
que la construction de l'europe est née
du refus des guerres
puis on a joué l'hymne européen l'ode à
la joie extrait de la neuvième symphonie
de
les couleurs de l'europe le bleu
symbolise le ciel donc l'idéal les
étoiles figurent les peuples de l'europe
et forment un cercle en signe d'union
une cérémonie qui a beaucoup qui a eu
beaucoup de succès particulièrement
auprès de nos cousins américains en
visite à paris ça vous a plu superbe
superbe